[Music]
you have to save yours and our
reputation the DEA murders in Silverado
remember that yeah two undercover agents
killed in a drug buy we're
DEA I got the marshals to agree to send
you down and bring those two witnesses
back
[Music]
here sometimes I mess around with movie
lines look what I mean mhm there nobody
else around
[Music]
here got a doctor fix you up the right
way this is my brother it's dangerous
the longer we here the more danger for
your family Joon has a few lives left
he's a strong
one she can help solve who killed those
DEA agents in America we can protect you
can I saw what happened that night and
they know
it so who do you know that you trust
that you can
call so many questions my friend
if you want to fight with the Wolves you
got to be a
[Music]
wolf